hey everyone we're sitting down with
sunny Jane from Sun genomics Ione thanks
for having me on the show I'm excited to
talk about the microbiome and now we're
gonna be talking about how the gut
microbiome affects our overall health
yeah that's right
we now understand just how much of an
integral part of our wealth wellness and
and even disease microbiome plays and
these are microbes that are living
inside our bodies affecting our own
physiology and potentially some of our
own digestive capabilities what foods we
can tolerate and even the likelihood of
some chronic conditions like diabetes or
arthritis or or other gastrointestinal
issues IBD is a big one so then there's
something that is going on between the
interplay of the food that we eat and
the way that the microbes are
interacting with that food that we're
eating and then potentially like you
were talking about all these other
intestinal problems that we can have and
disease so there's this whole interplay
going on it's very intricate yeah we
originally thought well I guess I
thought at some point through my
education I learned food was for myself
I can't always thought of food as
something I'm eating to feel my own body
and in the last five years and we're now
understanding food actually fuels our
microbiomes as well and the microbes in
our bodies that then either can fuel us
or have a different path and be
potentially bad for us and so you have
to be careful about food in some way
because you're not only helping it fuel
yourself but you're also fueling your
microbes of your body and your gut and
that's where the aspects of personalized
regimens become much more important
because we need to understand what are
the microbes in any one individual gut
before we can get into that journey of
what food is going to be best for us
yeah and as we figure out how to
individually maintain it to our
personalized lifestyle all
so in our personalized body also we
should understand like how to have a
strong microbiome how to have a robust
microbiome is there are there specific
ways maybe for like the general
population as well that is a good way to
have a strong microbiome yeah I we
learned this now you know as studies
come out about the evolution of your
microbiome you start to get microbes
colonized and transferred from from your
mother at birth and it begins to be your
seeded microbiota and over time that
that microbe population matures and it
becomes more and more complex as we
enter adulthood and so just tracking
that at the individual level and having
time points for you becomes an
understanding of what your personal
baseline is it's a very personal thing
yeah and and so once you understand that
personal baseline then you can
understand what a good microbiome is for
yourself as you were saying that I was
thinking about the beauty of when the
sperm meets the egg and then becomes an
embryo and the inside of a woman that's
developing at a pregnant woman and then
I was thinking about when the brain
forms when the heart forms when the gut
forms and when that first gets seated in
to the child and how exactly these time
stamps one year is zero when you're two
when you're six when you're twelve what
exactly happens to the gut microbiomes
through those periods of time and how
can we understand that better and it's
literally becoming you these microbes
yeah it's amazing that there's this
symbiosis between bacteria and human
cells and beyond bacteria other microbes
this this begins when we're age zero and
it stays with us through the rest of our
entire lives so we're just starting to
understand that transference that occurs
and if something in that process doesn't
go sort of the way that transference
would be beneficial for us
let's say you have to take an antibiotic
early on mm-hmm or something just runs
transfer of some of these good microbes
to our gut the antibiotics disrupt the
good microbes they kill good microbes
yeah that's right so they'll kill yeah
they kill the bad microbes as well the
infection but they're there they're not
very argued yeah targeted in that sense
and so they will kill the good microbes
that were also transferred to you and
that's how we lose some of the good
microbiome effects later in life and
we've begun to understand now that that
first thousand years of life is so
important to keep a nice healthy
microbiome otherwise you run the risk of
having some of these long-term allergies
asthma x' or even chronic conditions and
diabetes are now being associated with
impacts that were made terior early
microbiome mm-hmm but it's not all grim
there is there are solutions to manage
it and and one thing is is to provide
yourself with good microbes or probiotic
I was gonna ask so what is the diversity
of a diet that is kind of like known to
be a good good probiotics etc
supplements are always a good way to
boost a microbiome at some level but
then you guys have some supplements as
well we did so at some genomics we we've
got some precision probiotics
custom-tailored probiotic formulations
based off of what's going on in in any
individual gut profile and through that
you can begin to to manage your
microbiome for the first time and
actually take direct action that beyond
that then you can also keep that
constantly healthy right thinking about
what you do and eat throughout your day
now that microbiome is is with you in
your daily lifestyle and including your
morning routine potentially mm-hmm and
do people have to change their lifestyle
or change their diet as well as taking
the probiotic supplement you know we
feel that there there's always an
opportunity to make our diets better but
that recommendations been around for
years I mean go to your doctor and the
doctor is gonna be like you know what
need to do Alan you need to exercise and
diet better and I feel like I've been
told that all my life totally so that
for us at least at sons genomics we
wanted to find a way to engage people
into health and wellness that can boost
their current lifestyle right and
integrate with whatever lifestyle they
have from a diet aspect from an exercise
regimen that they're on or types of
supplements that they take so whatever
lifestyle that you maintain we integrate
with that so that we can just make that
better and sunny what is the golden
microbiome great question I don't know
if we've fully understood what the
golden microbiome is but Alan you have a
golden microbiome and I have a golden
microbiome and these golden microbiomes
might be completely different that's
what's so interesting about the
microbiome are our DNA's are 99.9%
similar and there's very small variation
there from human DNA but our microbiomes
the DNA of the microbes yeah they're
only 10% sim similar yeah oh my gosh
so that's an interesting one because our
whole lives were told oh we're so
genetically similar similar similar but
then where there's actually more cells
more bacterial cells we're actually way
more different in bacterial cells Wow
yeah and and so your golden microbiome
is gonna be different than my golden
wouldn't your very Wow
and so we we begin to explore that with
individuals so that they can understand
what they're they're good microbiome is
for themselves but also think about it
in the other way we do know what are bad
microbes c difficile pathogens things
that are going to cause inflammation in
our gut you know those are microbes we
can detect now very quickly and take
action on it and so let's solve for some
of those bad microbes if you will as a
beginning point and work towards our own
personal golden microbiome
yeah the difference is so crazy between
humans microbiomes and then like you
said the goal to microbiome for each
person it's different so we got to
understand it
yeah what's what is dysbiosis good
question a dysbiosis is a term that is
used to describe imbalance and so like
many things in the world there is a
balance and our microbiome also has a
balance to it so there's there's good
microbes and then there's bad microbes
and they have a ratio inside of our guts
at all times and if that ratio gets
thrown off from what is comfortable for
us and that is a dysbiosis so now you
have a lot of bad microbes and not many
good microbes to balance your gut health
and that's dysbiosis and that dysbiosis
can shift things for our human
physiology ship things like create
inflammatory bowel disease create
colitis create diabetes and so
monitoring that and managing that
becomes fundamentally critically
important to our health now and so
microbiome testing microbiome analysis
early to prevent dysbiosis is important
that's so interesting that despite OSIS
is the opposite of symbiosis then so
then when you're good health and you're
your good bacteria you're bad bacteria
are kind of at the same like level
that's more symbiotic and when it's
dysbiosis when the one of them is
outweighing the other one even if it's
good outweighing the bad potentially
yeah too much of good it could also be
bad in cases of things like sudden
intestinal bacterial overgrowth
it's called SIBO so if you over populate
a particular microbe it's taking up all
the space
yes you only have so much space in your
gut and if one microbe takes up all the
space then you don't have the benefit of
all the other characteristics of the
other microbes the digestive
capabilities and then that one microbe
is going to release a
a lot of particular metabolites and
that's where it could be a little bit
dangerous this seems like it happens a
lot to the to the starving entrepreneur
because the entrepreneurs are usually
eating whatever they can get their hands
on sometimes that's not that's the same
food sometimes it's unhealthy food and
so there's actually malnutrition and
micronutrient deficiencies that happen
across the world where people are only
eaten maybe one thing every day because
it's the only thing they have monetary
access to or even just grew food growing
around them access to so so that takes
up their whole microbiome then and
that's a that's a lot in one and not a
lot of other diverse like probiotics and
other nutrients yeah we didn't realize
how impactful the the different types of
macronutrients are to our microbiome up
until the last couple years where all
these studies have now shown and a large
body of science has developed called gut
science you know showing us how things
like fiber can change our bacterial IDs
concentrations and good right lots of
like good lots of fiber is good or
certain amounts of fiber are good yeah a
certain amount of fiber is good and that
might change the balance of a high
protein high saturated fat diet that
would feed bacteria T's to feed what
they call Faycal a bacterium the fiber
can support these commensal organisms
that are beneficial to our gut and that
can help prevent a lot of chronic
conditions if we become more mindful
about those things yes I still can't
believe that our guts are 90% different
from each other that is so crazy cool to
learn about and now we're gonna explore
more into what Sun genomics does so
thanks everyone for tuning in and we'll
catch another video with Sun genomics
soon